what is this place I'm sorry to be the
one to tell you this but you got
yourself killed
Vin Diesel is no stranger to comic book
movies he's the voice of Groot a member
of the guardians of the galaxy in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and he stars
in the Fast and the Furious which has
basically become a superhero franchise
but now it's time for him to physically
portray a comic-book character on the
big screen and bloodshot diesel is one
of the main characters in the valley
Comics adaptation a super soldier with
nanotechnology pumping through his veins
the vengeance seeking hero is popular
among a certain fanbase but he's not as
well-known as say Captain America so in
anticipation of the Sony Pictures
released here's everything you need to
know before you go so who exactly is
bloodshot initially created in the early
1990s in another form
bloodshot is one of the signature
characters of the Valiant Comics
universe in the recently rebooted
version which is the basis for the movie
he's a super-powered soldier for the
government whose real identity has been
wiped out and replaced by false memories
the movie follows his story from his
days as a Marine named Raymond ray
garrison who was all but killed in the
line of duty but he's kept alive by
scientists from a secret biotech project
who turned him into an unstoppable
killing machine meant for special
military operations his powers which
include various superhuman abilities as
well as regenerative healing are the
product of microscopic robots called
nanites that have been injected into his
bloodstream but he's also under the
control of those who made him what he is
bloodshot begins with diesel playing
garrison a u.s. Marine who got himself
killed in action or so he's told he's
turned into a super soldier and then
begins training with others like him and
a secret military program privately run
by the rst corporation eventually the
newly christened blood shot begins to
remember his past and how he was
essentially killed along with his wife
so he goes rogue on a mission of his own
to take revenge on the man responsible
for ending his former life but there's
more to his story than he realizes
as seen in the trailer for bloodshot rst
is manipulating their new weapon with
all kinds of false memories that give
him purpose on his various missions
after each operation he wakes up in the
same facility and has no idea who he is
or how he got there but we can expect
that at some point he figures it out in
addition to diesel the cast includes Guy
Pearce who plays the scientist who
creates the technology to power super
soldiers like bloodshot his role is not
from the comics but instead based on
similar characters involved in the
project one other known character from
the comics who is part of bloodshot is
acts a villainous computer whiz who is
played by Toby Kebbell a second solace
Sam Hugin Talulah Riley
lamorne Morris and Alex Hernandez also
co-star well Riley's character Gina is
from the comics the role may have been
changed slightly and the trailer she's
Garrison's wife who was killed on the
page she was his girlfriend and the
daughter of a mob boss that he worked
for as a hitman which exists since she's
tied to is likely to be part of the
mystery blood shot was adapted from the
comics by Jeff Wadlow known for his work
on kick-ass 2 and Eric Heiser who
received an Oscar nomination for his
screenplay for a rival so now you know
and now you can go see bloodshot and
theatres on March 13
you